first victim of the tragedy in the
english channel on wednesday has been
named iraqi national mariam nuri
hermadamine was among 27 people who lost
their lives trying to reach the uk from
france yesterday well i'm joined now by
our middle east correspondent alastair
bunkel uh alastair tell tell us more
about what you found out about uh murray
and hamadamine
yeah she's 21 years old she had finished
her university studies early in order to
travel
to the uk to be with her new fiance who
was already
in the united kingdom she traveled via
germany and france in order to then make
that final crossing across the channel
but she
we can confirm tonight is one of the 27
who sadly lost their lives in that
incident earlier this week we've spoken
to members of the family to her cousin
who told us this he said that her father
and mother are totally devastated the
situation is just awful she was a woman
in the prime of her life
it is a total tragedy and the whole
family are in shock and i can vouch for
that
we have been in contact with the family
and they are utterly devastated from
their home here in northern iraq the
cousin
went on to deliver a message to other
young kurds and there are many who are
either in
northern europe at the moment hoping to
make that crossing or they are here
where i am
with dreams of going to europe and he
said i understand why so many people are
leaving for a better life but this is
not the correct path it's the root of
death please don't take this route it is
not worth it and he had a message as
well to the british and the french
governments it was this
we hoped that britain and france would
accept us in a better way anyone who
wants to leave their home and travel to
europe has their own reasons and hopes
so please just help them in a better way
and not force them to take this route of
death we've got an image
of mariam with her fiance it is an image
that
you know so many people watching will
affiliate themselves with it is an image
of a couple
clearly deeply in love uh newly engaged
with hopes dreams uh of a life ahead of
them and those hopes and dreams for them
included
a life living in britain but it was not
to be
she died on wednesday along with 26
others
those identities are yet to be confirmed
and
we await on that but tonight
at least one family here in northern
iraq and a fiancee back in the uk
are mourning the loss of a young girl
who made that very dangerous crossing
and risked everything to try and get to
britain but didn't make it